welcome to Simon Dev in this JavaScript
tutorial we're going to be exploring
implementing a boyd simulation or a
flocking simulation depending on how
you've heard it described there the same
thing to begin boyd's is an artificial
life technique originally published by
Craig Reynolds in 1987 I've included the
link to both the Wikipedia page and
Craig Reynolds site below in the
description so if you want to follow up
they're great resources now I've used
this blocking simulation a number of
times over the years in various games
it's incredibly versatile as you're
seeing right now now all the code is
available online on github so take a
look if you're interested the link is in
the description below as well what we're
gonna go over today is what boys are and
thus what avoid simulation is and how a
simple and basic steering behaviors can
be combined in various ways to give rise
to seemingly complex systems I'll step
through how these behaviors were used in
our flocking simulation to create both
the underwater and the outerspace scenes
and what tweaks and changes I made to
the basic behaviors to try to make the
fish look more fishy or Zee spaceships
look more spaceship II steering
behaviors so what are steering behaviors
they're the simple behaviors we're going
to be looking at that when added up
together can result in an overall
complex looking system like will see in
our board simulation to begin our voyage
we'll just be wandering around not doing
anything other than that just kind of
minding their own business wandering
around not taking anything into
consideration this is really easy this
is just accomplished by having them
randomly move ahead and tweak the angle
occasionally so they turn and move about
a bit you can see that there's no
attempt to avoid each other at all or
doing anything else of interest they're
colliding with each other constantly
we'll go and add one of the first
behaviors separation and separation is
conceptually simple you look around you
and you steer away from any objects in
your vicinity
in this case we have a sphere
representing how far this point can see
and this look I can see around
he sees a bunch of other Boyd's and now
he makes an attempt to avoid them and
this is accomplished with relatively
little code all you do is you get all of
the nearby points you calculate the
direction to them and then you try to go
to the opposite way it's working pretty
well there's no hard constraint that
they can't overlap and we don't bother
with the kinematic non penetration
constraint that Craig Reynolds mentions
in his paper but if you look closely you
can catch them overlapping occasionally
it's not really a big deal
the next behavior is alignment and Craig
Reynolds defines this as steering
towards the average heading of local
flock mates again this is easy enough
everybody nearby we can just average out
their direction and try to move in the
same direction so what we do is again we
grab everybody that's nearby we query
for them we get the direction that
they're heading in and then we average
them all out you can see now that we're
doing that it's not quite as chaotic as
it was before you've got these little
groups that seem to be moving in unison
with each other they've naturally sort
of fallen in line the last basic
steering behavior we're going to look at
is cohesion and cohesion is really just
steering to move towards the center of
mass of local flock mates sort of like a
force of gravity for all the boys in
other words getting closer to everyone
and all this is accomplishing is giving
the group a bit of stickiness they'll
move in the same direction but they'll
also attempt to stay close to their
buddies now with this on the group's
sort of stick together much better and
if you see two groups collide
they'll probably merge into a single
upper group now the last trick is just
combining these in some same way in the
flocking simulation and it's not as
complex as you might think
it's really just about weighting them
appropriately and this is honestly where
magic constants and fiddling around
until it looks right comes in you can
see from this code that I've just sort
of assigned weights these were roughly
just guesses as to how important I
thought the behaviors were keep in mind
that some of these forces also drop off
based on distance so the weighting just
adds a level of priority
on top four that's it with these three
basic behaviors and avoids
implementation you can get some
incredibly complex and interesting
systems there's a bunch more searing
behaviors we can also add on top
the original Craig Reynolds paper just
specified the three but they've since
added quite a few check out his website
if you're interested but we've got
enough to do some really cool things
already I'll take the flocking
simulation with these three steering
behaviors and show you two different
scenarios the first thing we'll do is
we'll make an underwater scene now
originally Craig Reynolds developed his
flocking simulation for birds
hence the Boyd's name but with
underwater this is a lot of interesting
possibilities since it's very much like
birds in the sky except that you've got
an enormous diversity in terms of what
fish are down there that kind of thing I
whipped up a quick fish here and blender
as you can see blender is a free 3d
software package and my art skills are
pretty weak so uh yeah we'll start our
underwater boyd simulation scene with a
few fish what I was hoping to do is
mimic that variety of sea life that
you'd see down by the ocean floor so to
start I've taken that first fish model
and scaled it to three different sizes
small medium and large and you can see
them all moving around now but the whole
thing isn't really that convincing small
fish are really fast and turn on a dime
well bigger fish don't really dart
around the bigger they are they kind of
slower they move what I want to do is
capture that feeling in our flocking
simulation and the way we accomplish
this is by jacking up the speed on the
lower fish and allowing them to
accelerate quickly turn quickly and not
allowing the bigger guys to do that that
just means we'll throttle the steering
factor more aggressively on the bigger
fish so that they take longer to turn
and avoid things next it doesn't really
look right when a bunch of big fish and
little fish all try to hang out together
I imagine that some of those big fish
are probably trying to eat some of those
little fish so I think that those little
guys want to form huge fast schools and
the bigger ones can't keep up anyway and
the way will accomplish
this is by tweaking the alignment and
cohesion behaviors specifically what we
do is every fish only considers similar
sized fish when deciding to swim near
them and in the same direction that's
sort of looking better now
our Boyd simulation is looking pretty
good everyone has their own little
clique now the next thing we want to do
is remove the 2d constraint when it was
just combs it was easier to work with
everything in two dimensions just a test
but fish also swim up and down and again
we're gonna tweak this fish can swim up
and down but tend to swim parallel to
the ground so what I'm gonna do is wait
the steering factor more heavily for the
X said dimensions and only let the
up/down or Y dimension through just a
little bit now they're moving in all
dimensions and to me at least more
realistically they're not going up and
down as often as they're going side to
side which is at least based on my
viewing of fish and pet stores how they
act added about zero research so feel
free to correct me here in the comments
we're mostly here what I'm gonna do is
add some big whale things just to make
the overall scene a little bit cooler
and voila you've got an underwater scene
with a bunch of fish swimming around and
looks pretty nice considering the amount
of work it took I also made a space
scene and this was a little Battlestar
Galactica inspired I was thinking back
on all those battles with the Cylons and
I was thinking that this could be
totally done with a flocking simulation
and figured I could recreate it with our
board simulation there's only a few
elements here you've got these little
fighter ships and then the Battlestar
like cruiser things the first thing
we'll do is dump two of these battle
stars into the scene and space them an
appropriate distance apart they're not
part of the simulation because they
don't move but they do have bounding
boxes that the fighters will have to
avoid secondly we'll put a few hundred
of these fighters into our flocking
simulation mostly the same steering
behaviors that the fish have but again
tweaked a bit for the scene the first
thing we needed to do was remove some of
the rotational constraints that the fish
head
fish were constrained to stay upright
because I figured that was realistic I'm
not sure fish float upside down normally
unless there's a problem so the fish
models had to be constrained to stay as
upright as possible these fighters have
no constraints there's no up in space
and so we'll let them spin around
however they won't secondly we want two
groups of them one set of fighters for
each side so we'll assign teams to each
Boyd one will be red team and the other
one will be blue team and they'll sort
of attack the opposite side by having a
steering behavior which makes them seek
towards the opposite battleship
technically we can stop here but I'll
ladle on a bunch of effects I'll give
them all lasers which are in essence
super long thin billboards and I
actually had to implement this for
bullet trails for a major Xbox
Playstation game a few years ago so this
is the twenty minute version I'm not
going to go into detail but the code is
really short and you can just take it or
ask me I've also added a quick explosion
we just kind of want to pop out some
additive particles and rapidly
decelerate fading to red and then black
it's pretty nonsense how this is done if
a ship sees a ship vaguely in the same
area it'll fire its lasers and then
there's about a one in four hundred
chance that I'll just set off an
explosion on the nearby ship oh and I
added a bunch of random post effects
that three.js had lying around they look
pretty cool so enjoy now if you enjoyed
this video and want to see more like it
give it a like and hit that subscribe
button in the corner also if you have
any suggestions for what you'd like to
see in the future leave a comment below
until next time cheers everyone
you